[Applause]
discussion thanks Cory
yeah thanks Coby and all the organizers
for this fantastic week really enjoyed
it wish I could spend more of the
semester here with you all
yeah so this give me a little unusual
compared to I guess other talks this
week I'm not gonna be talking about
results or work that has been done
it is a forward-looking talk about
something that should be done in the
future and should be done collectively
by us as a community and so I want to
start a conversation around that and I
defined this idea and see if we can
figure out a path forward as a group so
this is inspired by work we've been
doing in the privacy tools project and
some at Harvard with Georgetown bu and
all our collaborators and so a lot of
people involved with the practicing
tools project have influenced what I'm
gonna talk about and in particular also
our efforts in developing SCI that James
Honaker talked about on the first day
kind of lead to some of the thinking
here all right so all right what am I do
I want to pitch I think it's the time is
ripe for us to really have a community
effort as a differential privacy
community to build a so the highlighted
words trustworthy and open-source suite
of differential privacy tools that can
be easily adopted by custodians of
sensitive data
and in this I want to focus on making
data available for research purposes
whatever one means by research why you
know so for the world I think there is a
there see there is a real need and
demand that we're seeing for for such
tools to be available that and I think
we're there there's been a lot of
progress in that direction but we're not
quite there and satisfying the the needs
and then from our perspective I think
the real incentive is to magnify the
impact of the of the work that we all
are doing so it's sort of try to try to
think about scope I have a few use cases
in mind and one we should feel free to
kind of talk about what what other use
cases make sense so the one that you
know we've been thinking about in the
privacy tools project most is is tools
for data repositories so James talked
about house I was gonna integrate with
dataverse but there many other data
repositories where human subjects read
it researchers which human subjects
researchers use to share their research
data with other other researchers for
secondary analysis and verifying their
results currently most of these
repositories are not really equipped to
take on and make available access to
sensitive data second we've heard a lot
about government agencies trying to make
data available to the public we've in
this week talked mostly about official
statistics and statistical agencies but
as has come up in the conversations
there are many government agencies that
don't have the statistical expertise of
the statistical agencies that are also
struggling to kind of respond to open
data mandates I mean I mentioned earlier
you know police departments and city
government and and so on wanting to make
data available and struggle
with how to do so in a way that's
protective of privacy and then a final
one that that has also been part of the
motivation some of you may have heard of
probably most people haven't this new
effort to make data from companies
available for research so there is this
social science one effort which is their
first project is trying to make Facebook
data available for researchers to study
election manipulation and while there's
a lot of thought has gone into the
infrastructure to to how such a thing
might be designed in a way that's
repeatable for many companies and many
different kinds of studies and they're
you know thinking about what are the the
raine you know how our researchers
selected and having that done in a way
that's independent has sufficient
independence from the company and how
are the set of research questions the
type of data that you're going to make
available how all that's decided but
something that's still kind of missing
for for kind of these efforts to happen
in a kind of repeatable and scalable way
is again the the tools for privacy
protection of sensitive data when you
make it available to the researchers so
all of these use cases I think they are
all compatible with focusing in you know
for starters in such a suite of tools on
you know on the centralized model of of
differential privacy and in part I mean
of course we're seeing many of the
applications of differential privacy are
not only the centralized model or the
local also the local model finding quite
a bit of use but it seems like at least
my my my thinking is that that would be
one should think about doing it having a
similar sort of effort in this direction
you know for for local DP but that would
be sufficiently different and not share
as much infrastructure with building a
suite for the centralized model and then
of course if the intermediate
multiparty models that might be used for
you know hospital sharing data and so on
and and that too would raise a whole you
know different set of challenges
alright so why why are we not there yet
so from kind of as I see it but when
people should feel free to push back if
this is not really an accurate view of
things so we've seen this week you know
particular think in the talks on on
Monday the huge amount of thought and
engineering that's going into building
really good DP systems for for example
the 2020 decennial really census but
these you know a lot some of course many
of those ideas will be generalizable but
they really being built with a with this
particular use case instead of releases
in mind and you know also maybe the same
is true of if one thinks of the local
model you know Google and Apple and you
know other companies using local model
building systems really for you know
collecting data of a particular type and
wanting to do particularly at the one
things that are more generalizable that
you know again an organization that
doesn't have the expertise and resources
that the Census Bureau or these big
companies have to be able to make use of
differential privacy we have lots of
wonderful academic research projects
that are producing software and tools I
think that are kind of leading to a lot
of the same same goals but most of these
are you know sort standalone projects
that don't integrate with each other and
we're not currently in a state where all
of the developments that are happening
across the community can be kind of
easily combined with each other and take
taken advantage of we don't currently
have a way that we are collectively
vetting the software that one you know
one group is producing is not being kind
of vetted by by the rest of the
community and
and because their academic research
projects often you know the goal is to
demonstrate that something is possible
be able to write some scholarly papers
on that and not necessarily to bring it
to the point where it's easily adopted
by by someone who wants to make use of
it and then there are some you know
closed commercial products that are
appearing and those may be good for you
know particular you know clients of you
know of those of those companies but you
know they don't kind of have the the
benefits of having kind of open tools
that can be that that have the kind of
trust that one can have when they're
produced by and vetted by an entire
community okay
so all right so what are some of the
things that we should be that I think we
should be shooting for or so open source
but that's not just you know having a
repository where the where the where the
code is available but really thinking
about how do we create a a community
that is committed to contributing to to
this to this single resource and we need
to think about what are the right
processes for for there to be
contributions and for them to be vetted
appropriately and then also what are the
incentives how do we give credit make
sure that there's a way that some you
know again most of us are our academics
and people are you know primary
objective we're certainly important
consideration is our career you know
career considerations what's the right
way that we can give credit to people in
the community for for those
contributions
all right vetting I mentioned a few
times right so there needs to be we need
to be thinking about what other in terms
of processes how to code that is
security critical or privacy critical
how is that going to be evaluated one
one you know thing that you know comes
to mind also in the in the way that
things may be deployed is that it
probably will be the case that one
cannot move the sensitive data around
you know due to legal constraints for
example
and so probably there's gonna be need
need for the you know the actual code to
be shipped to the data rather than the
other way around
tools need to be scalable and extensible
I think is really important right
there's a very rapidly moving field
where are our understanding of what's
possible and the you know algorithmic
developments are progressing it at a
fast pace ok so how do we architect such
a thing from the start to be able to
grow with the science advance with the
science and not have to be thrown away
you know five years from now so you know
some of the components alright obviously
a key component will be some library of
a vetted differentially private
algorithms vetted or formally verified
as the case may be but it needs to be
some process for for verification one
has to think about what are the you know
what are the the languages that are
going to be supported for that it will
it be multiple there needs to be
thinking of how does one make you what
are the what are the interfaces to this
and architecture around this set of
algorithms one can imagine that we think
is designed in a way that supports
multiple different interfaces some aimed
at less sophisticated users and some
aimed at at you know data data
scientists and who you know will will
write code what are the kinds of data
that's gonna the the format's of data we
heard in bullet I added after Michael's
talked this morning right I mean just
you know supporting simple flat tables
only or do we want you know to support
you know multi relational databases and
and so on and then there's a lot of
stuff that I am probably not the right
person to talk about that I'll just skip
over but are probably important and you
know I imagine that we want to have this
set up in a way that people can use the
the components
in different subsets according to their
needs and sophistication so you know
already just a library of vetted
differentially private algorithms could
have a lot of lot of use meaning first
you know sophisticated more
sophisticated organizations that want to
build their own DP systems but don't
want to start from scratch but then one
could imagine really you know also the
system as a whole being something that's
easily deployed by an organization that
has no differential privacy expertise at
all that where it's really you know a
service that will you know manage budget
and generate differentially private code
to run on the roommate remote data sets
allows for both you know releases as
well as interactive queries and so on
you know different extremes of this we
need to think about what kind of team
there needs to be it needs to be you
know obviously is some sort of
leadership for this sort of project of
people who are kind of trying to
maintain a consistent direction for its
its growth which you know hopefully be
something that could a team that evolves
over time but then maybe some way that
people in the community could be you so
there's this if we have this human
vetting of code right you need a team of
people that are going to be you know
vetting contributions maybe doing
optimization on or taking things from
the literature and adding it to the the
library so you know should there be a
way in which people can come and spend a
portion of their you know researchers in
Commons DP research and come in spend a
portion of their time contributing to
this effort you know these are these are
a bunch of you know roles that that that
come to mind again I'm not the right you
know having never really been part of an
effort like this we should probably
learn from other major open source
projects what kind of organizational
structure is effective and another
question I realized that you know can I
was missing in the initial list that we
we had for this sort of thing is what
should be the right kind of domain
experts representation from the you know
eventual user communities of these
things in in the
team that's developing this system right
so if this is a plausible idea what are
some next next steps one we hold some
kind of workshop that's around kind of
really fleshing out how this should be
structured and really I think learning
from other major open source projects
raising funds assembling a team and then
thinking about you know we've heard how
I think John made the comment during
Michaels talk having some real use cases
is really important even if the goal I
think is to build generalizable a
generalizable system and and having
those as sort of providing also a
deadline that by you know one year out
we want to have something that's not
just open but actually is ready to be
used for certain you know particularly
use cases so now that was like I said I
wouldn't talk for long so a bunch of
questions for discussion I really want
to want to open up I mean one basic one
for this room is like what would it take
for something like this to to engage you
all what in terms of how it how its
structured or what the incentives are
another is is this you know we should be
realistic is is do we believe some we're
ready for something like this in the
sense that if we're building kind of
again a generalizable suite of tools can
they be actually useful enough without
the kind of extensive engineering that
has gone into the you know big
deployments of differential privacy so
far those set of use cases that I those
are kind of I guess prototypes of use
cases you know government data data
repositories and companies making data
available for for researchers is that
the right set of things are there other
ones that we should be talking about or
drop some of those that in because they
will involve some complications that are
too difficult can we
the architecture thing that will will
really allow it to evolve with the
development of the field I mean I think
I raised a lot of these questions before
and then this is there's this question
so about the type of vetting of the
software so it was nice to see in the
talks this week that the formal
verification of DP has advanced a lot
and and becoming a lot I think
easier to use and more general in terms
of the kinds of things that be formally
verified is that at a stage where it's
ready to to to say that that's the way
that codes gonna be added or if we have
to go with manual vetting of
verification of differential privacy is
that gonna be sufficiently scalable so
let me let me just open it up and
thoughts reactions that's pretty much
all I wanted to say you're getting
engaged
simply knowing that something is going
to be used and some form of capturing so
people using things from this repository
if they say well we're actually using
this for the following in a way that you
could that it was recorded in this site
and someone could point to it and say
something I wrote has been used I think
that would be a fairly significant
incentive but it means that people who
have to use things out of the repository
have to be willing to say they're using
it which I think as much it's probably
the hard part of that yeah maybe if this
is set up in a way that it can somehow
by default track that sort of thing but
you know possibly giving people the
agreement say you agree if you're using
something there's repository to let
people say you're using it and that's a
that's very different from what people
are used to yeah so one sort of natural
tension that might arise inside I think
we now have a market for DP engineers I
mean there are companies who want people
trained in DP and they would love for
people to basically work at this
organization that you're setting up here
for six months a year or two and then
steal them away so it's great on the one
hand but I have a feeling that they're
gonna be companies trying to steal all
of your employees can you take advantage
of knowing that there's that demand and
maybe structure things for example so
this is a place where a company can send
a top engineer for a six-month
sabbatical you they pay them and you
give them the DP training and benefit
from them
yeah that's a that's a really that's a
steal the people you're paying to train
but rather have them paid no let me just
put it let's use we instead of you in
the John so without trying to make this
sufficiently too broad it took too broad
but it's sufficiently your focus
there's also efforts like this going on
and the reproducible science domain now
these are very similar structure not
quite the same problem but they come
together in many of the social science
disciplines with discipline journals
being unwilling to entertain submissions
that can't be verified in some
reasonable way so combining efforts to
do privacy enhance data analysis with
efforts to document reproducible code
streams lets you partner with more
agencies like icpsr is a good example
that part's reproducible science parts
share a lot of the infrastructure that
you're talking about here that got
offering up differentially private
analysis routines or formerly private
analysis routines and possibly a policy
where general referees are allowed this
bucket for examining the data that there
that opens up a lot of possibilities
that could bring in you know
demography science as partners in this
effort - yeah we think about which of
those we should be trying to at least be
compatible with if not share
infrastructure with with an effort like
this so I try to think Rachael then
Thomas to Deirdre and Adam okay
schools for a while 3d their privacy
tools project that of Harvard Kate you
talked about how much progress you have
made so far versus how much of this is
left to be done yeah so we we you have
to our our you know our James talked
about kind of where we were where we are
on Monday and we really have kept our
while a lot of this stuff about
eventually having an open source library
where things that we always talked about
as a long-term goal our main focus has
just been trying to like make progress
towards integration with dataverse right
as the you know and and there's a lot
here that very small suite of
differentially private algorithms most
of the effort has been on like what what
is the wrapping the interface and the
the back end that's going to be needed
for it to be able to integrate with
dataverse and but we've been doing it on
a you know shoestring in terms of like
the number of people so it's small
certainly a lot of thinking in this
direction and a small amount of progress
but I think here is something of a
different magnitude I mean I hope the
work we've been doing will will will
will be a good you know will help in in
this in this sort of effort so there are
people publishing papers under eventual
privacy around the world they have
but the full standalone clothes I think
we need to think about how to
incentivize those people to integrate
their code into the system and one
suggestion that I have is that there
should be some benchmarks and the
systems within one of the benefits that
they give is they integrate their code
they can run it on the benchmarks in
compared to what everyone else is done
and that will help them publish their
paper rather than having a small
computer oh I'm not sure whether or not
like I feel like there's some danger and
suggesting that there's a bunch of tools
and you can take them but use them given
having spent here - the complexity and
the level of detail at which you have to
understand how what sort of questions
you want to ask all these things and
I've been concerned about some of the
kind of ANOVA the machine learning as a
as a tool oh yeah just come and use our
algorithms and you'll get answers and if
you put this out there as a tool I feel
like you might actually encourage people
to do things with they're like oh we're
doing differential privacy we're doing a
great job and they're actually doing
their really crappy implementation and
so I feel like you know maybe it's
differential privacy out of there's a
suite of tools but it's a service that
there are I think you would want the
expertise or at the very least you would
want a lot of documentation about what
are the questions you need to answer
it's like beginning
because I think the truth of the matter
is that a lot of people don't understand
the way the folks who've been here for
the past week talking about their
struggles with hearing implementations
people don't even know the right
questions to ask and so I would be very
worried about making this alike off the
show come grab some tools yeah yeah
that's a that's a really good point in
in terms of how this is made easy to use
correctly and to make sure that people
don't have disasters with it different
thank you
so let me try to Adam Marco
Rocco Ashwin will go on the circle like
that it probably makes sense to identify
a smallish number of open-source
projects that have been successful
regardless of domain and see what makes
them tick and what does work and not
work who the contributors are I don't
think actually there are that many open
sore big open source projects that are
where most of the contributors are like
research oriented academics yeah you
know okay it's your favorite joke about
like red wire and whatever so we could
think about what the model is in one
specific example I think that's
important that the various crypto
libraries and this sort of comes both
too dear just point and Katrina's point
about model about the model of the
economic model which is that first
falling in with crypto libraries you
it's not expected that you can use these
as like a total novice I mean they're
relatively simple to use but you know
they are do come with various warnings
handle with care and then if if I
understand correctly who's actually
writing that software and I might be
wrong a lot of the contributions come
from actual companies and stuff that are
using the software and they contribute
code to their work to the project
because they see a sort of a real
benefit in having the common code base
that they can point to that they're
using the thing that everybody else use
it's like there's this whole number of
places where there's a real benefit to
that and privacy security yeah it's a
good point fits really well with the
model that Katrina was suggesting - yeah
I mean I mean it's these are all
important questions and certainly
Kryptos harder in the sense that picking
security parameters in crypto is much
simpler as thorny as it is as a much
simpler problem than say that they point
to the more in tariffs ocation but
penguin versus automated verification
but one what I think here we have a good
occasion in the sense that the community
starting somehow something new so
integrating some verification would be
good from the start and I think we don't
have to commit to a terminal or
committed wave cannibal combination
where when there is the manual betting
we have some support for the people that
do the math on that thing so something
of this kind I think it would be a good
and for them and a good occasion for the
community to have something that is a
bit more reliable than just few people
checking it right right think of it like
a almost like a proof assistant yeah
yeah to follow up comments to what John
said and what I I think the the
replication community idea is great from
the perspective of the AIA be there was
such a compliment listen we often have
this problem that papers published on
the administrative data we can never I
mean to certain journals you can set
them or you have troubles convincing the
editor that there is the procedure with
which you can replicate in-house but
because it takes so long to get the
approval and in replication itself
wouldn't be allowed in many cases
because it doesn't had anything new so
so they I really would be harmful and I
wonder if if those two even have the
chance to be then very simple because
the model is already known the very
other lying on and and you only need
enough you know precision to get to the
right conclusion you don't even need to
necessarily get the right in the same
coefficients I think having something
simple there that would help this is out
of the out of the the the launch at
manator said that you were working with
a way to create a such simple to
basically DP the sample that we work
with would be a huge service to all of
those using this panacea and then
follow-up to what the other said the
American Association for public opinion
research they have this transparency
initiative and is sort of the seal for
data collection that follows a set of
steps that if done I mean if it needs to
know what's going on there and all of
these decisions point and that that
might be a model to to think through
what would one need to know so that they
are not saying is like oh I employed
tips i DP algorithm and that's it
self point on one key difference between
crypto so there's a big common I didn't
tiptoe in fantasy and so I think sort of
trying to take some of the lessons
learned from crypto here would be very
very useful but there is a big
difference between the two communities -
you would like to go you would like to
start off with use cases where we know
we might be successful which are cases
where you have lots of data but lots of
data means you know you must have a
system that can be architected that
could handle that lots of data which you
have to mention so definitely this
effort has to engage people who know how
to handle what you did I think that is
very important things explore again have
experience put it in not handling doing
it a lot guitarists it is very very
important in the second point of
introduces I think the Proteus mind
thinking about how we can teach people
to do analysis under service the
constraints is an important thing and
one thing you want to think about in
this effort is really what kind of
education we can
bringing me it's not only just very easy
code but also education right so educate
yeah
so not just documentation for the data
custodians but they for the analysts
were gonna be using these systems as
well all right so I think I saw aloni
and comments about replication made me
think about it
there's commerce there's discussion the
machine learning world about
over-dependence on benchmark benchmark
data sets and how the only thing that
matters is you get your extra point one
percent in accuracy right and people are
wrecking the people in that world
recognize that that's a problem so maybe
just throwing out an idea like what if
we got a company somebody like Google to
produce a new benchmark data set for
machine learning model some huge voice
that is an image recognition is
[Music]
hey heard you yes few problems at once
you have this have this behind like use
this as a holdout behind differential
privacy which gets at some of this over
dependence on these benchmarks if it's
the new big data set that everybody will
be testing against and m/l researchers
will make you motivated to use it there
reducibility concerns might come along
with so you have in mind this the
connection between differential privacy
and false discovery when you talk about
like the holdout and having buy-in from
like some people on the machine learning
community to use this to solve their
problem to which is overfitting and over
reliance and benchmarks yeah I certainly
I've heard in conversations from from
for example the social scientists that
one of the appeals of such a thing could
be this like if you can tell people that
they also won't make false discoveries
if they use this it'll it will help a
question I have for those who have been
thinking about the false discovery
problems more as whether that theory is
that the say at the level of maturity
where it's ready for to you know give
people quantitative information about
false discovery or not I just haven't
been tracking it closely enough but it's
it certainly something that I think that
holds appeal for potential users yeah I
just wanted to follow up on what Ashwin
said in terms of if your page and I
think I feel that now is this there's a
stage now for TP wearing you know it's
moving to the next level on some sense
that it's I mean I can see that the term
popping up everywhere and I had even you
know a venture capital firm
asking me whether it's worth to invest
in the DP market but I feel that a lot
of these people they really don't
understand what it's all about and they
still feel it's like you know this is
just the panacea the solution for
everything and and not even
understanding that you know you have
still this trade-off between utility and
privacy they just think you know you do
that and then everything is protected
and we are safe and so I think if this
should be applied another the more on a
broader level and it should be like a
general tool I think there's a lot of
teachings still required in general not
even only for the users but there's Cali
calibrating expectations is really
important yeah that we're not the next
blockchain so for example in our a eyes
try to achieve in Germany our government
all Paul talks about the country privacy
but they don't really have an idea and
so I think that's it so Cynthia and or
maybe not trying for the industrial data
set the kinds of data sets for
benchmarks that would come from census
were very sensible agencies to
prioritize their effort in that
direction I had something else to do
thanks for your very first bulletin I
think everyone here is deteriorating
systems in the discussion I heard lots
of really interesting ideas it's the
service and then datasets but I actually
feel that we are not the right set of
people to be asking about this that with
no disrespect to Katrina's economies
like she doesn't really know how to
build such a it feels like a non-profit
company basically or a non-profit
service that maybe needed a governmental
support not not-for-profit business
owners of meteors or I think to get
these kind of things started what do you
need we can come up with a bunch of
values but they're probably very very
good at research because it's not
necessarily true I mean the systems
community has been building tested
building things like fire lab and then
somebody has to start the separate and
then it gets taken over by a larger
organization
I mean the fact that you know this and I
don't already points out to how it would
at least iron how to construct such a
for-profit business and again I'm
putting myself but I don't think it I am
alone with the lack of knowledge about
yeah I mean I think these your point is
aligned with what Ashwin said earlier
that like you have to make sure you have
the right expertise and such a group and
it's not clear that we're representative
of all the sets of expertise but there
there are a number of other successful
open source projects that at some point
some of the really big ones I guess did
transition to like sort of being their
own little like nonprofits but you know
III could name there are a few that come
to mind but I don't know I don't know
enough about them to know if they're
really good examples you know are are
are the language is an example is this
as it is and other you know you know
OpenSSL and things like that or you know
they're very successful widely used you
know I'm sure there are lots of failed
examples alright so any last
yes yes
maybe this is an opportunity as well as
a risk and I think if you do this it's a
big educational opportunity as well so
that now with that needs to come the
education but it's a way to get the
world engaged in this to bring real new
spaces I think there's a lot to be said
for getting the non-academic
and then you can get a lot of heavy
lifting perhaps yeah it's a really great
idea and I think also resonates with I
mean ORS comment which certainly hits
home for me oh the idea was to really
engage software developers uses an
education in industry as kind of along
the lines of what Katrina was suggesting
here's an opportunity to educate them
and then get a lot of the heavy lifting
and code development to be done by you
know professional developers and
Industry this just came out
sure I think we are out of time okay so
I think one interesting example in terms
of like turning like cutting-edge
science into working or are like linear
algebra libraries so if you look at the
Blas and la park-like behind these
implementations which have like lots of
subtleties similar to the one defining
leap in terms of like changing people
thing strategy will change your
stability along so on top of this code
there's documentation which has like
math paper form but with more detail
proofs that would usually find in papers
who is going to take the responsibility
of reading that and vetting that you can
you know thinking the community
ya know but letting the users vetting
the cold one thing that helps a little
bit is there aren't that many different
differentially private algorithms that
really get used heavily and that is
there are many different differentially
private algorithms but they rely on a
relatively small or trusted components
there's you know res edition and with a
few different distributions there's
exponential mechanisms alright this came
out very clearly Michaels talked this
morning and that you have these small
number of components that you carefully
verify and then some way of you know
also verifying that they're used in a
plan and a correctly simple thing what
you do is you make funding we're
available is to have like a bug bounty
for our my are use you know if you
people people who find for the state's
get money for and not just money
academic credit you know they get to
read papers and it's a really
interesting mistake but somebody has to
check their claims and they come
well money yeah again you know that
requires funding it requires as you say
were kind of and the Salil said you know
debted people who are dedicated to the
project at least on some timescale long
enough to 90% of algorithms then it's a
very narrow band of techniques and maybe
we could water made that checking and
just restrict ourselves to dealing with
the remaining 10% of the other thing I
wanted to suggest was that but what we
can't automatically verify differential
privacy most maybe we could come up with
a set of sanity checks they were just
you know someone added 1% of the noise
that was opposed to I think we're out of
time but as I said this is a
conversation to be continued I didn't
hear anyone saying we shouldn't do this
which is but what I would like it also
let I'm sure you'll all have more
thoughts do share them and in particular
and to ORS point you know this this
thing cannot be all just flying on like
a complexity theorist who hasn't written
code in 20 plus years so people who are
really interested in being engaged not
just once this thing is out there but
from the start and in structuring it and
helping getting off the ground I really
would love to hear from you
[Applause]